it's Leviticus 11 Deuteronomy 14 where
God distinguishes between clean and
unclean animals and
why these animals well he doesn't come
out and tell us but I'll give you an
example of the wisdom of God are you
aware Beth that every animal and foul
that God prohibits are scavengers they
feed off of dirt rodents so to eat them
is a sure way of getting your your body
sick
what do pigs eat dirt mud so if you
consume
Pig it is harmful to your
body think about the other things that
God forbids you from eating for example
catfish or shrimp catfish and shrimp
feed off the garbage of the sea or
Eagles or Hawks they feed off of
rodents right so notice the wisdom of
God in that the animals and the fowls
that he prohibits you from eating are
exactly what Timmy tempy bear said
Bottom Feeders that are unhealthy for
your body to
consume so you see the wisdom of God the
things that he forbids you from eating
are animals that feed off of debris dirt
garbage they're Bottom Feeders
cockroaches rodents Hawks and Eagles and
so in other words you see God's wisdom
in that the animals and the fowls that
are prescribed prohibited are animals
and fowls that actually do irreparable
damage to your body physically so you
see God's love and wisdom in prescribing
clean animals that will not harm you
physically because God is also concerned
not just about your spiritual wellbeing
but your psychological and physical
well-being he's concern he's concerned
about all of you the whole of you makes
you wants you to be whole and healthy
spiritually psychologically emotionally
and physically you see the was of God
even fat God said you cannot eat the fat
of the animal it's forbidden go to
Leviticus 17 10- 14 you'll read he
forbids blood and fat fat you are not to
eat the fat of animal and we know that
fat contributes to heart disease because
as Sal John said the Triune God Yahweh
yahweh's father son Spirit knows what's
best for you because he knows his
creation better than creatures
do you got
it even though now even though
now as Christians we can eat anything
that doesn't mean though I have the
freedom to anything I should eat
anything right moreover the other reason
why Leviticus 11 Deuteronomy 14 God
distinguished between clean and unclean
animals clean and unclean Birds you know
why the New Testament gives you the
answer there's another
reason it goes beyond the physical the
physical benefits and health benefits
right the
blessings of eating the diet prescribed
by God the health benefits the physical
benefits and blessings there's a
spiritual deeper Rich meaning to
distinguishing between clean and unclean
animals clean and unclean Birds you guys
want to know what it
is it's found in Peter's vision in Acts
10 9-29 I'm not going to read it we're
going to look at key points acts 10:9 to
29 Peter sees a vision where he sees a
TBL spread coming down sees it three
times coming down okay in that Vision he
sees clean unclean animals and
birds a voice tells him the voice of God
says get up Peter kill and eat Peter's
response no Lord I have never eaten
anything unclean the voice says do not
call anything common or unclean that God
makes clean he saw that Vision three
times he didn't understand what it was
now open up my brother Acts 10:1
17-20
sure acts 10:1 17:20 eating clean is not
what makes you good it's obeying God's
command that makes you good so if God
tells you eat this and you do then
you're good don't eat this and you don't
then you're good so it's not the eating
per se that makes you good it's the
compliance and obedience to God's
command that makes you good or bad
because what is sin breaking the law of
God okay now read for me acts 10 17 to
20 now while Peter wondered within
himself what this Vision which he had
seen meant behold the man who had been
sent from cor Cornelius had made in
inquiry for Simon's house and stood
before the gate and they called and
asked whatever Simon whose surname was
Peter was lodging
there while Peter thought about the
vision the spirit said to him behold
three men are seeking you arise
therefore go go down and go with them
doubting nothing for I have sent them
now how many how many men three now
notice who's speaking to Peter the Holy
Spirit notice who's commanding Peter the
Holy Spirit notice who sent these three
menant to Peter the Holy Spirit now
notice How Majestic glorious and
wonderful and beautiful the holy spirit
is number one the holy spirit is a
person he speaks and commands he's not
an active Force so much for the Joe's
witnesses number two the holy spirit is
the Lord God of the church because
notice he commands Peter he tells Peter
what to do when to do it how to do it
and Peter must obey or suffer discipline
so it shows you the holy spirit is the
Lord God of the church he orders the
church he commands a church and he tells
the church what the church must do
number three no notice it's the Holy
Spirit who brings people to Salvation
because the holy spirit says I brought
these men to you do not hesitate go
immediately with them you see how
glorious the holy spirit is it's the
spirit that convicts you of your sin
it's a spirit that makes you aware of
your sin it's a spirit that shows you
you need Jesus and it's a spirit that
brings the right teachers to preach the
gospel to get you saved the Holy Spirit
does it from beginning to end you see
how much meat there is about the Holy
Spirit in those two verses but another
connection are you ready for another
connection you guys are you up in a
alert are you asleep another connection
how many Gentiles did the Holy Spirit
send to to Peter how
many three how many times did Peter see
the vision of clean and unclean animals
where God said do not call anything
unclean that I made clean three times
three three times
right okay why three
times because each Vision represented
what the man the Gentile three men three
men three times he's told don't call
anything unclean that God makes clean
because the three-fold vision
represented the three Gentiles whom God
was about to make clean therefore Peter
don't you look down upon them and
consider them unclean because God is
going to make Gentiles clean with you
but there's another reason why three it
is the work of the Trinity to make
anyone clean it is the work of the
Father the work of the Son and the work
of the Holy Spirit to make anyone clean
so three men three visions three persons
of the godhead the
Trinity sing
in y cuz he went silent no I'm hearing
you okay why three times three Gentiles
whom God is going to make clean but also
it is the work of the Triune God to make
anyone clean it's the work of the Father
the work of the son the work of the Holy
Spirit these three persons of the
godhead they alone are God who makes
anyone clean so now let's see how Peter
interpreted the dream how Peter
interpreted the dream go to acts
10:28 he's now entered cornelius's
house in fact read from acts 10 read
24-28 watch here guys and the following
day they
enter
um what at the following day they enter
CER ceria ceria Philippi I can oh man
I'm sorry that's okay you know why CIA
Philippi is
important what cesaria Philippi was the
the place where Peter confessed Jesus
Christ is the son of the Living God and
pet and Jesus said blessed are you Simon
bar Jonah Flesh and Blood did not reveal
this to you but my Father in heaven and
I say you are Kea and upon this Kea I'll
build my church in Matthew Matthew 1613
to 18 it was at cesaria Philippi where
The Father revealed to Peter by the Holy
Spirit Jesus is the Christ the son of
the Living God which then moved Jesus to
say you are the rock upon whom I'll
build my church and I'll give you the
Keys of the Kingdom of Heaven that what
you bind on Earth will be bound in
heaven what you loose on Earth will be
loose in heaven is it a coincidence this
is the same place that Peter now opens
up the kingdom of God for the first
Gentile
family is that a coincidence
H you see the rock discharging the keys
by opening the Kingdom of Heaven for the
first Gentile
converts at the same place where Jesus
said to him blessed are you Simon bar
Jonah for Flesh and Blood did not reveal
this to you but my Father in heaven and
then I read 18 and I tell you you are
Kea and upon this Kea I'll build my
church and then 19 in Matthew 16:19 he
says
and to you has been given the keing Keys
of the Kingdom of Heaven what you bind
on Earth shall be bound in heaven what
you loose on Earth shall be loose in
heaven and here that same place cesaria
Philippi Peter discharges the Keys of
the Kingdom of Heaven by opening the
kingdom to the first Gentile convert and
the Very place where Jesus said you are
the rock you are blessed and to you have
been given the Keys of the Kingdom of
Heaven
coincidence oh no are you guys being
blown away how deep and Rich mute me
buddy I can hear myself through your
computer how deep and Rich the
scriptures
are now read 25-
28 got
you as Peter was coming in Cornelius met
him and fell down at his feet and
worshiped him but Peter lift him up
saying stand up I myself am also a man
and and as he talked with him he went in
and found many who had come together
then he said to them you know how
unlawful it is for a Jewish man to keep
company with or go to one of another
Nation but God has shown me that I shall
not call any man common or unclean okay
I'm
confused when did God show Peter not to
call any man even Gentiles that the Jews
thought were unclean common are unclean
when did God show Peter
that in his vision ah now if you guys
have been paying attention here is the
interpretation why God during the old
Covenant period distinguish between
clean and unclean animals and other laws
that were given for Israel because the
animals represented Nations the clean
animals and birds represented Israel who
at that time was the only nation set
apart for God's glory whereas all the
other nations were allowed to steepen
their sin now
however the time had come for even the
Gentiles to be made clean so now and
making all the animals and birds clean
that was a symbolic act by God to
showing that the Gentiles will no longer
be alienated and considered unclean the
Gentiles will be now cleansed by the
blood of Jesus Jesus through faith in
Jesus born of the same spirit and
they'll be one with you so the animals
that were given in the Old Testament
were intended to point to a greater
spiritual reality like they were clean
animals and birds in distinction from
unclean animals and
birds similarly the nation of Israel was
that clean animal that clean bird that
God distinguished from the unclean birds
and unclean
animals typify by the Gentiles and their
idolatry and immorality but no more no
more so everything in the Old Testament
has a deeper more Rich spiritual meaning
everything even the dietary laws even
the priesthood the sacrificial system or
why the Jews could not use two different
threads for clothing all of that had
deeper richer spiritual significance
that points to Jes Jesus Christ and his
church all of it I'm not exaggerating
the duty of the student of the Bible is
to see how all these commands point to
the Lord Jesus Christ and his church and
his work on Calvary and bringing about
all the nations cleansing them by his
blood making them one with the
Commonwealth of Israel